Now, worse part is the
Old New York speaking of,
of the people who are
older people are retiring.
They can't stay in New York state because
it's too expensive, too expensive.
So they pack up and go to
a North Carolina, South
Carolina, Florida. Is it taxes,
real estates?
Both its taxes and it's an opportunity.
It's both of those two
things, right? So it's so,
so they decided to head on down in
North Carolina, South Carolina, Florida,
Tennessee. They actually have
a name for us in the Carolinas.
They call us halfbacks. We went to
Florida and halfway back. That's true.
They calls halfbacks.
That's how many New Yorkers go there.
But he's the worst part. Go
to Florida. Go, ah, this is
a mistake. There we go. Say,
well the sad part here is though,
Florida actually has more people than
we have and half of our budget and,
and Scott actually the governor Scott
actually thanked Cuomo for sending all the
people down there because 15% of New
York state's budget is actually pensions.
And so many people who are pensions
are actually leaving New York state and
going someplace else.
So New York state,
people are paying for the pensions and
then they're being spent in other states.
It's a terrible idea.
We, the state is broken.
It is so broken and people are
talking about if you're Democrat,
you're saying everything's still great.
If you're Republican, you're saying,
well tweak this or tweak that.
I'm saying rebuild from scratch.
There are things you have to change.
You have to change the route so you
can make the branch is actually died.
We keep clipping branches,
the weeds to keep growing.
Now we got way off track with this um,
school shooting thing.
And I wanted to get back to it because
I think it's a very complex issue and I
need is,
I don't know what the answer would be.
I think there is no one in town,
right?
I think you've found problems and these
problems that you're willing to discuss
it. Very few people are. Yep. Are
these people are lonely and sad,
but it's a public suicide and that
they're on psychotropic drugs? Absolutely.
And I don't know why you don't think
that other people want to fix it.
I just don't think that they have a
solution that they can discuss that is not
so controversial that it overwhelms
the rest of their messages.
What could be done? Sure. I
have a couple of answers. Okay.
The issue is this is an issue that's
been going on literally for decades,
so there is no do this and it's done.
Right? Right. There are several things.
One of them is fixing education.
The other one is fixing family courts
is said two things. You can start slow.
We'll show how do you fix education?
Absolutely.
It is a complete reboot right now.
The first thing you gonna do
with education is you want
to make sure there is no
standardized testing until high school.
None whatsoever.
Santa's nice testing is bad for
several reasons. Number one,
it's an unfair way of getting teachers
right teachers and are graded by how
their students do on a standardized test,
which is silly.
That doesn't mean you're a
good or a bad teacher. Next,
it makes a bunch of kids who are 10
11 1213 years old feel stupid because
they're not good test
takers and you create.
Now a secondary class of student for
absolutely no reason because the next
reason is standardized testing is
no indication of success in life.
You could be a great test taker at 12
or 13 or terrible test taker and it does
not mean you'll be successful
or not successful in life.
Last is how New York state,
often we'll decide how to fund schools,
so it's a way of funding schools.
That's also unfair.
There's no advantage to standardized
testing except it meet means the federal
government now begins to
control our schools more.
So when you say the standardized testing
has an, there's an effect on funding,
does that mean that if a school does
really well, they get more money? Yup.
Often it's part of a,
a very complex algorithm that New York
state has that almost no one can actually
find. That seems like it
should almost be the opposite,
that if a school does poorly that they
should put more resources into that
school because it's not being
effective in theory. That's true.
I'm not sure that's accurate either.
We,
we throw about $22,000 per student per
year in New York state more even in
California and it doesn't work.
We have mediocre results at
best dollars isn't the answer.
It's revamping the system.
Right? Funding is not the answer.
So how do you revamp the system?
There's more parts of that.
First one was just covering of that.
The second thing is we shouldn't even
have k through 12 k through 12 was an
anachronism and shouldn't exist because
the last two years she be k through 10
the last two years of high school
for a huge chunk of people, Jim,
study hall,
Video Games and probably smoking weed,
just nothing but bad foot.
Too many students just
sitting around doing nothing.
They have no purpose. They had no
community. They have, they had no,
no reason to do anything.
They're unhappy. Right?
Another reason why they're unhappy.
It's not a gross generalization that
they're unhappy and an unknown thing and
you just probably a lot of kids listening
to this that are 16 and 17 they're
working their ass off right now and I
have a passion for that future and I have
a solution for them. That's even
better. I have a solution. Again,
your limits that's going to keep
moving. Okay, go ahead. Right.
First thing is how do I know
what I just said is true, right?
You just asked that question. I'll
tell you why. What I just said, why no,
it's true because for the vast majority
of students going to college now,
the First Year of college is 13th grade
because they're not ready for school
because the last two years didn't
prepare them for college. If it did,
we wouldn't require it. 13th grade,
I don't know how to say 10th grade.
The average student now take
six years to graduate college,
so the results show me that I'm correct,
right?
The results of what's happening
and here's the worst part.
Now we shipped these kids off to college
who many of them don't even want to go
to college. So we sent him anyway.
It takes them six years to graduate.
The 24 years old with at least 50 k in
debt, if not more, minimum for decay,
some a hundred k something,
200 k depending what it is.
And now there's no job for what they
want to do and now they're working at
Starbucks. Wow. What a disaster that is.
We wonder why our kids coming back home.
So how about this, since that at 10th
grade took a test, you pass the test,
you get diploma. Whether you were
home, school, private school,
Public School is yours.
Awesome.
Now you have five choices and
this is exactly to your point.
You have five choices. Choice number
one, you're a kid who's hardcore.
You think that college is your answer?
Good. Go to to your prep school.
Imagine that kid who right now
he just had is busting his ass.
He could be in as in a prep
school of his choice. And,
and the people in that prep school are
all kids who want to be in that prep
school.
It would change his entire situation,
no more knucklehead who don't want to
be there, who are forced to be there,
who are cutting class.
The kids who would be there
are those who want to be there.
The teachers and in this planet,
no disciplinary issues.
They kids who want to be there better
for them. They could hustle better.
Now they're ready for college.
When they get there,
they take advantage of incubators of,
of internships.
Maybe even graduating three years now.
The Rock and roll them less debt.
Better off life is good. Better services,
better everything for less money.
I'm not done. You're not that kid.
You're the kid who is super smart human.
Become a scientist. You want
to be, get a phd. Awesome.
Go right to an associate's degree.
Start right away. 16, 17, 18,
continue to agree because you're that
good. Take your sats. You're that smart.
You're Einstein. Awesome. Go do that.
Not, you know, want any of those things?
No worries. Cool to it's school. Uh,
become a plumber or a carpenter, Mason,
whatever the case,
let me go do it.
New York state desperately
needs tradesmen desperately.
The average trade's person in New
York states about 50 years old.
Too old for an average should be 30
something for an average 35 and before an
average,
it's too high,
which means we have a lot of
trades jobs that are not filled.
I mean a lot of foreign labor, it has to
come to New York state, right? New York,
your kids aren't doing it.
Why we've been told a lie and that
lie is the only way to success.
The only way is to do well in high school.
Get a great for you degree and go get a
job and sit behind a computer all day.
That's a lie.
That is a way to success.
It is not the only way to success.
There are a lot of kids now,
and I'm sure you know people like
this who they spent the first five,
10 years of their life trying to make
it that way, struggling through school.
Then at 28 years old, they go, I
just want to build houses, man.
Then they go build the house or that's
what makes us so to be a computer guy and
they just make apps. He's
gonna do something, want to do.
They should have been doing that
at 18 well, I'm still not done.
Most people though,
they don't know what they want to do.
This is a big part of it. I get the
whole time, don't have a passion.
They don't have a direction
and they're confused. Yes. I,
this is one of my biggest complaints
I got about this plan, right?
Because then the two ideas are
because he'll get a job, right.
Just go work or sort of
business and what you just said.
That's why I get all the time.
But Larry, they're 16 they're not.
They're doing good.
Make Your mistake at 16 not 26 we're
making mistakes at 26 and we have people
who are lost at 26 we
have a generation now.
If you ask the people in their twenties
right now across this across this nation,
and you say, do you feel like
an adult over half will say no,
have have you say no 40 year olds
also though? Not as much, but yes,
but not as much though. It probably would
be over half. It won't be over half.
Okay. You go to your 20
somethings over half will say no,
I don't feel like an adult.
Right,
because they're making the same
mistakes that many people May,
1819 16 they're not making a 25 26 28
it's also not a rights of passage things
though thing that actually happens.
This would actually be that.
They'd have to make that choice
at 16 but here's the issue.
How do I pay for it and it covers the
entire sheet that we just talking about.
That's the next question I get. How
you paid for it. New York state says,
I have to pay for full 12 years of
school. Have to pay for it, stay next,
pay for it. No worries. I was a
marine when I got the Marine Corps.
I got a Gi bill x dollars,
I think it was $100,000.
I forgot what it was back then. This
is in the 90s. Um, I think at $100,000,
like 10 years to use it,
we're going to give all of our kids
$20,000 and five years to use it.
They don't get the physical check,
but the state will pay a check to whatever
school they want to go to for $20,000.
They have five years to use it.
Where does that mean? You can at 16?
So experimenting. You can say, you
know what? I know colleges for me,
I'm gonna go to prep school. Here's what
I promise you. I promise you this, the El,
but any amount of money you want,
I promise you this.
As soon as this comes into play,
you will find tons of all of a sudden
prep schools and trade schools the pop up
and guess how much they're
going to cost for two years,
$20,000 that's going to be a
tuition. You might say, well, wow.
Laris a lot of money. It isn't. We're
paying $44,000 now, if each of those kids,
we're saving $24,000 per kid and
giving them better schooling,
more accurate actual choices,
they can learn something.
They make their mistakes at 1617 which
is way better than 26 or 27 and maybe
they figure what they want to
do. Well, why is it so cheap?
Why are you going to be able to do that
for $20,000 when it costs so much more?
Now? What's going to be different? The
people who can be choosing, right? Yeah,
so the people that are
educating these people, how are
they going to get paid? Oh,
and where's the money gonna come from?
Great question. Now, a couple things.
Remember teachers ask me all
the time, they say, Larry,
how are you going to help us?
Here's what I tell you.
I'm going to get rid of a bunch of
your administrators in New York state.
We actually have school districts that
have more administrators than teachers.
Why? Yes, that's correct. Do you own home?
What's the value of having administrators?
Because you have to check
boxes for government.
You have to check boxes for coming. Did
you do x that you do? Why did you do z?
These administers required, that's
what's going on. That's correct. There's,
there's about $60 billion in our
budget in New York state for education,
give or take about 4 billion
comes from the federal government.
About 35 billion comes from the state
and about 20 billion comes locally.
Give or take it a d. These
are round numbers and they
change yearly depending on,
on, on who you talked
about. It's about that.
Once we get rid of the federal
government, being involved in, in the, uh,
in New York state for being dollars
goes away. People get afraid. Oh my God,
we lose that money. Good, good.
Let it go away because all of
the administrators go away. Also,
if you can get rid of three, four, five,
six administrators for every one or
two teachers, oh my God, I'm not good.
You national educator. But I
would imagine that if I was, uh,
I would be upset at this.
I would say that there's a reason why
those administrators are there and we need
them to take some of the administrative
weight off of the teachers.
The teachers are stressed out
enough by teaching students.
They don't have the time
to be taken care of.
All the formalities and the things
that these administrators too. Um,
I have never heard that ever
because that's not true.
You're the first person that ever said
to me ever in over a year of me doing
this. So, and the reason is,
or what are those administered
with you? No, no, no, no.
Not every teacher. I never
heard it. You never heard it.
I'm not just talking to a lot of, lots
of them. Doesn't absolve them. Does,
what did they say about administrating?
They say awesome. It's not in those words,
but yes, because most of the
administrators are actually
administrating teachers.
The teacher telling them
how to teach, what to teach,
when to teach, grading them.
They don't. Who Will the parents?
Well, the parents will. Yes.
You think the parents have the time or
the of what an education should comprise
of to be able to direct not just their,
their student,
what their child needs, but you
know, a group of 50 or however large.
The classic question and generally
speaking, probably not, but teachers do.
Teachers too. Yes, they're going to self
police. There'll be some administrators.
You're, you're assuming that I'm going
to get rid of all administrators. No,
no I'm not. I'm not
saying that. I'm saying,
but you're definitely saying that
you went to school with a, hold on,
you went to school.
Do you remember how many vice principals
that were any of your schools you
remember? No, I don't. Probably
two or three. That was normal.
It met most schools when I was his goal.
Often it was two or three.
I don't remember.
Now there's 1212 ten four two.
Why?
Why is that? Because their administrators
and they're making sure other things,
they're making sure boxes are checked.
So here's your alternative.
You're alternative is keep funding
a broken system and be afraid,
which is what you're saying. No,
I'm not saying you're saying,
you're saying teachers will be
afraid because afraid. Yeah,
because I afraid who educated our kids?
No, no. Overwhelmed. Overwhelmed. Okay.
Fear of, of being overwhelmed.
Not just, not just that,
but also like having
a mandate like having,
Yup, a very strict, I'm
with you. Curriculum. Yes.
Teach these children and that
is nothing but a bad thing.
I'm going to give you real
fast if you don't mind them.
Me Give you a list of all the time.
Centralized control has worked. Finished.
Centralized control doesn't work
in in education meaning what?
In anything when a centralized
control make things fun. Bet defined.
Centralized control. A strict mandate from
Albany, a strict mandate from DC. I'll,
I'll ask you a question.
I'm assuming you're old enough that you
were in school at one point at 1980 or
older. Oh yeah. Well before I was, yes.
Prior to 1980 basically the department
of education didn't really exist as it
does now. It did exist, but it was
basically as a repository for information.
It didn't really do anything.
I didn't have any power since 1980 up
again and have power do this and we'll
give you money. Don't do this. We don't
give you money. Here are your rules.
Follow them. I'll be punished you
that. That's what they are now.
You learn to read and write. You learn to
function in society, so to die somehow,
every American part in 1981 to school,
learn how to read and write,
learn how to function in society.
Somehow it worked.
Do I trust the administrator or a teacher?
I would rather trust the teacher. Now,
does that mean it'd be no ministers?
Of course, that there'll be a minister.
Of course they will be.
There'll be still principles and
things of that sort of course,
but the difference is an administrator
cares about checking a box, check a box.
Your citizens aren't better
off because boxes are checked.
You said it's a better off because the
students are getting better and and
because the parents are happier.
Right,
but when you're saying
boxes being checked,
that means things being covered that
they feel for a standardized test. Yes.
You two said that they feel significance,
correct? Yes. Well that's someone,
I mean I would said,
I don't know how curriculums are set up,
but I would imagine that
people get together and they
decide that children need
to have a certain amount of
ability. Yup. With grammar,
certain amount of understanding
of mathematics. Yes, I agree. Yes.
Who's going to do that? How about
teachers and the local administrators?
And how about the local PTA,
which was so less administrators,
not an elimination of administrator. I
never said that. So I didn't say you did.
But how we decide how many administrators
are necessary and how many can you cut
out? How much money can you
save? And this is even better.
You know that you're going to love
my libertarian ways on this one.
Right now what happens is there is
a convoluted way of deciding house.
What a convoluted way. Oh, I thought
you said come loaded. Did you hear that?
It could be, but no, I don't think it
alluded to compliment complimentary way.
Like this is a new word and I don't think
it should be used as that. Is that new?
No, not convoluted. The other ones, yeah,
I'm loaded. I was like, this is, boy,
there's a fetish there somewhere.
I'm sure there is.
I just haven't heard of me there.
See you. You're ready to go now.
So there's a calm that a way of
actually of funding these schools.
I don't want that.
I want to be very simple.
I want a flat fee to come
from the state here, district,
depending on how many kids
you have, here's your money.
What does that mean? Well,
the reality of it is there are about,
if I'm not mistaken,
about 700 school districts in New York
state. A lot. A lot. That's a lot.
It is a lot. And so what happens
now is there's your money.
Most of them are going to make no
changes because they're gonna be afraid.
But it's like anything else.
There'll be early adopters and early
adopters are going to say, wait a minute.
So the federal government
isn't telling us do this.
The state government isn't
telling us to do that.
So we can change some things here.
So when you say here's your money,
they're going to get less money than
they're getting now. It depends.
It depends on the school district.
Some will, some won't there.
It's not like you'll have less jobs there.
They're going to have to decide whether
or not they [inaudible]. You got it.
Exactly right. Yes. And you're
saying, oh my God, that's scary.
Some of our school districts will
fail. Yes. But in New York state,
they're all failing now,
so why do I care?
But the west trailers in mass right now,
I'm okay.
I don't want government to be
what you always hear, which is,
you know, elections
have consequences. So I,
when I now get to impose my will
upon all of you, because I won.
So what I say goes, I'm supposed
to know everything, be everything,
create boards and make things happen.
I instead want to be the guy who
when you have trouble, I can help.
So as go districts begin to have trouble,
I will without question,
try to help them. Of course I wrote,
but there's 700 that's correct.
How would you have time to
do that? I won't. Personally.
I'll have people who would ever,
right now there's already an
infrastructure to handle that already.
I don't have to create a new one
already exists, but right now it's just,
it's making up reasons to punish people.
I don't want it to make up
reasons to punish people. I
want instead to say, okay,
this school district is lost.
How do we help?
I only have one string
attached to the money.
I give only one and that is transparency.
As I told you before,
I'm a business guy and here's what I know.
This is an actual equation that
works every single time. Very simple,
simple equation,
personal freedom plus transparency
plus accountability equals innovation.
If we do that,
the other adoptees will come on.
They will find great ways
of making things work.
They will get rid of some administrators,
they will get rid of them. Teachers,
they will hire new ones. They will
decide which one should be given raises.
That will happen. Okay, please go ahead.
Because what you're saying may work in
the world of business because people have
incentive to succeed in business and
that accented IV is monetary success when
you always monetary, but yes. Okay. Not
always, but for the most part. Yep, sure.
When you're talking about a school yet
and you cut the funding for the school
and say, hey, figure it out.
You guys decide how many
administrators you want to keep art.
The administrators'
essentially the bosses,
aren't they the ones who are in control?
I mean they're not going to
get rid of their own jobs,
so what are they going to do?
You're going to pay the teachers last and
they going to get an inferior teachers
and is a great question. Ramp
up their, their control of the,
of the cash flow because they realize
that there's less of it. It is, oh,
it's a great question and here's the
issue. It's not going to happen overnight.
It's not like I went in
November. I go, great,
all the money's gone to how it works.
I went November.
People know what the plan is.
We start talking about it already.
We start bringing parents on board.
We said, coming up with plans already.
The plans, it's like, it's like
it's like any other organization.
You're saying business and think,
oh, it's works in military.
This works in this works in business.
It is matter what's in everything.
We'll see your family.
It doesn't matter if you knew that six
months from now you were going to have a
sniff decrease in your income, you
would start to make change. Typically,
if there was someone above you saying,
hey Joe,
you're going to have a decrease in
your income. How do we make this work?
What can we do?
If someone's there to guide you and
you already have infrastructure there,
you'll begin to fix it.
My fear would be that they would have
less teachers and they would have the
larger classes. Totally possible
administrators because they're in control.
People don't like to give up control
unless you're a minute control. Well,
who's actually in control with the PTA?
Right? The pantry. Dissociation can.
You can have a lot PTA board decide.
Boards would decide,
but they would have to agree with you.
Yes.
They want to get rid of administrators
and if they didn't universally,
if they didn't universally across the
board in this fails miserably and then
classes get larger and then
kids get less attention. Yup.
And then the already Piss poor education
system sinks further into the abyss and
we have two choices. Number
one, we can be afraid of that
and stay a hostage to a terrible system
that's not working as failing our kids
and making us in happiness Jordan estate.
That's option one or option to
do that and just watch over it.
Right.
Understanding that that could happen
because those were the only two options.
One other option, the other option is yes,
funded more. Ooh, fuck the bad system.
Boom. No. Why that? If
you had a 10 what's,
what's wrong with the system?
What's go over that I just
told you I don't know but no,
but I mean in terms of like how
much money are they making, right.
And what would increasing
that amount of money enhance.
Okay.
Two things.
Remember the first thing is there's no
way in the world that a governor should
be deciding what every teacher
makes. An estate. Okay,
that's just philosophically wrong,
so I'm never going to do that.
That is simply philosophically wrong.
It's against who I am. Centralize,
centralize.
Control was a bad idea.
Localized control is always a better
idea for so that's so that, that premise,
I'm never going to even touch that.
What I'm trying to achieve
here is to make change.
I know that locally there will be people
who do it right because that always
happens. That's just how it works.
You will see out of seven districts,
some of it decide to, you know, get
together and and and mix this together.
Some will decide not to. Some will do
different things. You'll see it happen.
My point is this is a major overhaul.
I get it right?
Businesses that all the time,
families do all the time.
If you're able to watch it,
I don't want to be the
mother or the father, right?
Democrats will be your mother.
They would give you everything.
Probably going to be a father and
protect you from everything. I wonder,
your brother, let me to got you love.
You don't want to live with them,
but you love him. And when you need a
ride to the airport, he's there for you.
And with the firefighter, the guy
who comes to help when you need me.
Now you're saying, but Larry
is good. This will fail. Yes.
Some ways I want them saying, well, okay,
some might fail. That's you're saying.
I'm not even saying they might fail.
What I'm saying is that you're going to
put them in a compromised situation. Yes.
You're going to give them less money and
you're going to say figure it out. Yes,
but not just see. You're assuming that
it's just here's money. Good luck. No,
here's less money. Yes,
he has less money. Yes.
I think you have too many administrators.
Yup.
And let's talk this out over
a series of several months.
When you talk to
professionals and educators,
do they agree that they have too many
administrators? Oil wasted money? Yes.
So far everything's your,
I've met, they want,
but they agree they do well with less
money if they didn't have to miss as yes.
And how much less money are we talking
about? I'm not sure to be fought with you.
Not sure yet.
There's someone show you that you feel
like the way to fix the education system
is the cut funding that would like for
people like me who are on the outside,
you hear that and you go,
Ooh,
I already feel like teachers
are underappreciated and
probably because of that
unmotivated because you decided
to say the answer is cut funding.
It's not what I saw. No, no, no, no.
This is what you were saying. Yup.
Regardless of what you're saying. Yup.
What I'm saying is currently, Yup.
Even in California, forget
about New York. Yup.
I feel like teachers are underappreciated.
I would agree with that and I feel
like it's a noble profession that's
incredibly valuable and the people
should be able to make a decent living.
Agreed.
I don't know how the solution to that
is to give less money to the school.
You're missing a very valuable,
very important point.
If you ask most teachers whether
underappreciated, most of them,
they're not going to say that people
like you and I don't appreciate them,
they're going to say,
the system doesn't appreciate me,
and that's why they're always
fighting the system. Oklahoma,
they fought the system.
They're always fighting the system.
What I'm saying is fix the system.
The system is heavily controlled in
many cases by the federal government.
$4 billion worth.
So we have to lose $4 billion unless we,
unless we want to keep the
federal government in our system,
but you don't want that.
Your fixes to let them figure it out.
Get the federal government out. Hold on,
let them figure it out with less money.
I have to have to push back
here. Okay. You, you keep saying,
let them figure it out as
if I'm just gonna walk away
and say, oh well good luck.
I hope I'm going to go off and now you
know, hang out in Puerto Rico for a while.
No, I'm saying I'm going to facilitate
it because you know what I do?
I trust teachers more
than trust administrators.
I trust the local people that
if I give them the right tools,
they'll do the right thing,
but more importantly they'll
show others as also transparent.
What's going to happen is they're going
to figure out the right way to do what
teachers should.
Should School district one hire more
Spanish teachers versus going to stick to?
I don't know.
I'm not supposed to know that,
but they do and if they make
a mistake then they'll fix it.
And then other counties, yes, you.
Are you talking about the teachers
themselves or are you talking about these
administrators who you want to eliminate?
I'm talking to you about the
school boards. The school,
the school boards are going to be
the ones with, with the PTA, with,
if we make this work the right way,
it will be everyone talking together.
It will be school boards
talking to administrators,
Toma teachers talk with parents.
I don't want schools graded
beat by standardized tests.
We've been doing that for years and
we have very, very unhappy people,
unhappy students, unhappy parents.
I want parents to be happier.
I supposed to be happier and
you might say, but then Larry,
they won't learn certain things.
Is that a horrible thing?
I'd rather than be happy
then learn AP chemistry. Yes.
If that means one school nurse decides
the AP Chemistry isn't that important in
a school district,
it's fine.
Those kids will learn it in the prep
school and some kids won't learn AP
chemistry.
If that makes your school district happy,
I'm okay with that because
it goes to the next level,
which of course becomes kids with special
needs. You have a special needs kid.
How do you make that kid happy?
How do you decide whether
that kid successful or not?
The standardized testing doesn't work.
What do you do? He said doing checkboxes.
Does that work?
Of course.
That's why you literally have hundreds
of of parents every single year suing New
York state because they were unhappy
with their kids getting services but not
getting better.
I want your kid getting better.
You're assuming that because the federal
government puts these standards in it
that makes them good or bad. It doesn't.
If anything, it makes them worse.
If my kids, if my kids are
happy, that's what I want.
Happy New Yorkers means
they stay in New York.
Happy New Yorkers means they grow
their businesses in New York.
Keep the families in need.
I get that,
but saying happy and the saying that
solution and the key to happiness is
funding them less and getting rid of
administering my the Democrat Joe,
I'm the Democrat. Yes you are. You ought
so a democrat. How am I a democrat?
You got, I mean the world's ending
less funding means the world's anymore.
A lot of people, they hear that you're
going to take money away from school.
The person who only hears that,
if the person says all he's going to do
is get rid of money from schools, that's,
that person is never going to vote for me.
That person is probably a democrat.
That problem's person's going
to go for Cuomo and that's fine.
I'm not going to win everybody.
I can't win everybody,
but I'm going to change a system that
is completely broken. If you say this,
what you're talking about people talk
about with the MTA also in New York City,
the MTA,
you got to keep funding the MTA.
I'm not going to be hostage to a
ship system, period. I don't care.
I'm not going to be
hostage to a shit system.
This is a terrible system
that is failing New Yorkers.
That is failing people in New York City
when it comes to the MTA mass transit.
I'm sorry. Yes. If those of you who
are not in New York, it's a bad system.
I'm not going to be a
hostile because of fear. No.
I will fight my jailer period
and my yellow is a system
that is broken that says
if you, if you, you better give me
more money, otherwise it'll happen.
You better give me more money.
Otherwise this will happen. No, no.
I'm going to fix that system. I'm going
to help facilitate fixing that system.
I'm just going to let them go away.
I'm not saying that.
What I'm saying is I'm going
to help facilitate that
system and to do that we're
gonna lose $4 billion and we'll
get over that. We'll fix that,
we'll make it happen.
We'll make it work so by and if you get
more people into this state and this is
the most important piece,
you can raise money through other ways
and just raising taxes on people and this
is the most critical piece when we
hear funding, and this is why I'm,
I was teasing you and Kanya Democrat
because we need to about funding.
You're talking about more taxes.
I'm not talking about that.
If you get more people to
stay in New York state,
you raise your revenue without
having to raise taxes on anybody,
but if you raise your revenue,
we're going to put more revenue
into the school of course,
to be more people in the schools.
More reverent. Yes, absolutely.
Your money and there'll be more
people in the schools that more.
Of course we would if we could
re of course we would. Of course,
New York state has a $170 billion budget
with about a four bay now deficit and
$300 billion in debt,
and the answer for every Democrat
Republican is more funding.
There's going to be nothing left.
This state is going to go different.
It's going to go, it's gonna,
it's gonna go under in 10 years.
How do you get more people to come
to the store, right? First thing,
we're having a really super cold cases
and I talked about super cool education
that'll get people to come back.
Are you going to hire someone to create
this super cool education system?
Are you gonna let these teachers figured
out on their own? If we hate teachers,
build me a super cool education
system so that we get more fun.
I already have the, I already have the
infrastructure for the super cool system.
I just told you. I've already told
you what the, what the instructor is.
Then the concept already a
skeleton is already there. Okay.
Now once I went in November,
we begin to build it out and yes,
it will be me and other people be clear.
It's not like New York
doesn't have enough.
New York's doesn't have enough workers.
We have tons of workers that we can
absolutely use to make this happen.
Tons of them that if I'm not mistaken,
the New York state has the
most by percentage, uh,
government employees I think.
And I think in the nation,
I know we're the most unionized,
but I think we're the most, uh, uh,
government employees by percentage or
you're going to move their jobs. Sure.
Love it. Yes, let's do
that. Love the idea.
You're asking details that are simple
to fix when the time comes and simple to
fix. So you're going to take people out
of what professions and move them into
fixing.
I think I actually have decided for every
person in New York state where they're
going to do, I don't know. That's why
I'm asking course not you. This is a,
you're doing it like a show. Now. I'm
not doing a show. You, you're a democrat.
Look at you. You're a democrat. You
are a democrat. I'm not, I'm giving,
I'm just asking you a
real clean questions here.
You four times said you're going to take
money away. Flicks. You are right. Yes.
You've said like four times,
right? Because you going on
about these other things,
which is what matters more than losing
$4 billion from education. Right?
But I just want to be clear about what
you're saying about what the actual going
to fix this system by creating a good
skeleton off the bat that people are going
to enjoy and like,
and then once I went in November,
we're going to fill that skeleton up
to make an amazing school system that
people can be proud of.
They're going to want to bring their
people then to come back from North
Carolina that had come back from
Tennessee. They're going to move from,
from Pennsylvania and Massachusetts.
I'm going to be part of this system.
They're going to see schools
that actually work well.
They're going to see prep
schools get kids into college.
They're going to see colleges and actually
educate kids and get them into jobs.
When they see that happen, they're all
start coming. That's going to happen.
It doesn't happen by me saying,
how do I fund this?
being afraid of making a step.
You don't have to have the
perfect plan to move forward.
No plan is perfect anyway. You want a
good solid plan with motivated people.
If you have motivated people to take up
a plan, it'll wind up being successful.
Again, it's how it works. So
this grandiose plan is I like,
you're going to get rid of the last two
years of high school and you're going to
offer potential prep school for
children and you're going to,
for other kids, offer them
trade schools, schools. Sure.
You're going to get rid of $4
billion in federal funding.
You're going to let the schools figure
out how many administrators they should
have with help with help, with
help, and what's the help?
Who are you going to hire it oversee
this whole thing? We'll figure it out.
You figured that out.
Look,
I'm two months from the election and
from the election and then at least six
months from fermentation,
right? At least if I met,
that's probably low by mark
nine put anytime this is,
this is come into play until next
September. Right at earliest. Right.
The earliest you can come into play is
next September. I hope it's that fast.
That'd be amazing. I hope it is that
fast, but it isn't five minutes.
It's like I'm not doing
this so I can become king.
We would have a king and that's
why we're in trouble. Right, right.
I want to give localized control
many more options. I, I'm the,
I'm the crazy guy who actually means what
he says. When I say let teachers teach,
I actually mean that most
people say it and then they,
and their response then becomes,
give more administrators.
So you think what's stopping them now?
Standardized tests and
administrators and then funding.
That's based on the success of the test
and it's correct in the school district,
correct.
The answer is always more funding.
The answer is always more
funding and it isn't.
It is not that people always
say we have to fund fund fund.
That is not the answer there. There are
better answers out there. Of course.